Since the days of Dean Martin and the Rat Pack in the 1960s,...
...Las Vegas has been renowned for live entertainment...
...and between showcase fights and residencies from Lady Gaga, Celine Dion,...
...Britney Spears and Magic Mike,...
...the city is constantly raising the bar with what it has to offer.
Its latest offering, developed by Madison Square Garden Entertainment...
...and located just off the strip behind The Venetian,...
...is unlike anything anywhere else on Earth.
Known as the MSG Sphere, 1.8 billion dollars spherical entertainment venue...
...will stand 112 meters tall, contain 17,500 seats...
...and feature the largest and highest resolution LED screen in the world.
That's 19,000 x 13,500 pixels in case you were wondering.
The screen covers an area larger than three football fields,...
...wrapping up, over and behind the stage...
...to give the audience a fully immersive experience,...
...that's 100 times clearer than today's best HD TVs.
Outside, the building is gonna be covered with 54,000 square meters of programmable lighting...
...giving those who can't get in a show of their own.
But the MSG Sphere is more than just a high-definition screen.
Using an advanced acoustics system known as beamforming technology,...
...multiple audio streams can be delivered directly to individual seats simultaneously...
...while an infrasound haptic system will use vibrations...
...to enable guests to quite literally feel the sound around them.
It's not just those experiences that are unique,...
...the way the building is being built is also unlike anything seen before.